good afternoon my name is Philippe
vergara i'm the founder and CEO of yummy
Hume is a company that manages funds
that invest in low-income students to
allow them to go to college we don't
give students a loan we provide them
with financing and they commit to paying
back to fund a fix a fraction of the
future income for a fixed number of
months we currently work in four
countries which are chile colombia
mexico and the u.s. we have today a
question from our boosters Miller the
question is what keeps you motivated
Thank You gue support for the question
well I think that what you feel
motivated is the idea that I can have a
positive impact in the world to my my
work this is what has what drove me to
create unique almost ten years ago I
think that one thing that is very
important for me is to see young people
evolve grow develop and something that I
think is really important is that young
people have hope I mean one of the
saddest things that you can see is when
you see a young person like a teenager
or an early tomm on him in her early
twenties and they just don't have the
idea that they can do something and can
improve their situation so I am
profoundly motivated by this opportunity
I think it's a great cause and I am just
very happy to do it as a an entrepreneur
and as a social entrepreneur there are
12 days it's not easy to build your
dream but i would say continuously
encouraged by this
of being able to transform a life of
other people something that is also
great is to see people evolve i we have
financed as of now two thousand students
in the four countries where we work and
it's really incredible to see the
transformation of those young people
some of them we can ask them when they
were 19 or 80 years old we coach them we
help them understand what it's called
it's about go to the costs of college
graduate and in some cases will also
help them find jobs and then is
incredible to see how they get their
first job and keep evolving and then
also and then also start coaching and
training your younger younger students
so I think that this cycle of hope and
developing those young people is really
a lot of is really very encouraging and
exciting for me thank you